so one of the things that an infinite
mindset provides
is um is a sort of what i would call a
a quiet confidence or a calm confidence
so
for example if i were to tell you
there's going to be a massive snowstorm
or a massive hurricane in next thursday
you're right all right it's going to be
awful it's going to shut down work
not going to get to work i may
telecommute i may take the day off
it's definitely going to hurt a lot of
companies right
gonna hurt if you're in a it could
destroy a farm
right um but we've had lots of
hurricanes
we know how to deal with it we know how
to prepare for it we know there's gonna
be a short-term hit
and we kind of like we know how to ride
it out
right well most of us live 70 to 80
years old
imagine if we lived for a thousand years
this would be like the sixth or seventh
pandemic
right that we faced in our lives it we
know it's gonna hurt we know it's gonna
but we know it's gonna
be over and we know we know there's
gonna be pain and we know how to prepare
for it
yeah so what an infinite mindset
provides is it helps you see
what we're going through now not as the
end but rather
just part of the journey like it's a
it's it's
it's hard and it's difficult
but there is a light at the end of the
tunnel we're in darkness but we we know
this comes to an end
we also know that life will not be the
same afterwards this is like world war
ii it's like the way life was before
world war ii is not what life was like
after world war ii
the way that life was before this
pandemic will not be what it's going to
be
when we talk about going back to normal
there is no going back to normal
yeah as a friend of mine called it the
other day which i like we're going back
to abnormal
yeah yeah it will be different we don't
really know how
but this is what's really important to
remember is this is
uh not without precedence which is we
have gone through things before that
have shaken
the business world sometimes forcing
companies out of business
what do you think the internet did i
mean the internet
you know put a lot of companies out of
business who couldn't adapt to a new
business
to the new change um and it created new
businesses
and some businesses were for forced to
adjust
some proactively and did very well some
defensively and they're still trying to
figure it out
streaming put all video stores out of
business
didn't have to but it did starbucks when
starbucks would come into a neighborhood
people would complain that starbucks
would put mom and pop coffee shops out
of business
actually the data shows the opposite
that when starbucks moved into a
neighborhood
um mom and pop coffee shops absolutely
did better
because it brought customers and people
had a groundswell for the for the local
business
the ones that went out of business were
the ones that couldn't adapt
they still had that old ripped-up couch
because they had a monopoly on coffee
shops and when starbucks came in with
nice clean stores
they simply complained about starbucks
and they went out of business it's like
taxis complaining about uber
an app doesn't put you out of business
you can have an app to hail a taxi
it's because you have a you have to
adapt for the changing times
for new technologies new companies new
competition new ways of doing business
and if you don't adapt you die now
that's not
universal some companies like video
stores some companies
this is just too much to bear and and
there's there's very little we can do
but but but to think of this in terms of
what skill sets do we have what is our
why and how else can we bring that to
life
it's this is way more sudden than the
internet it's way more shocking it's way
more
unnerving but it's not new in business
we know how to do this i read of i'll
tell you two stories there's a
there's a restaurant in new york city
called res dora it's a pasta restaurant
it's a relatively new restaurant it's
only been open about nine months so
they're still on you know they're still
making a name for themselves
and of course when new york city issued
the order that restaurants could only be
fifty percent
these guys uh saw the writing on the
wall
they could see that this is going to get
worse
so they immediately started to adapt
their company so instead of firing
off firing all the waiters saying we
don't need waiters anymore
they changed everybody's job so all
those same waiters are now packaging
food and organizing
online orders and call-in orders which
by the way they had to develop this is a
a high-end restaurant they didn't
deliver food they had to immediately
figure out how to do that
but the point is everybody kept their
job because they changed their jobs
so just as the company had to adapt the
people had to adapt as well the people
who said well i'm only a waiter well
i got no job for you yeah and so what
we're experiencing even in our own
company
which is we're forced to adapt we you
know we do
live events well that doesn't exist
anymore
so i have somebody on my team going i'm
only going to do live events well i got
none for you
right so we have to adapt as individuals
as much as we have to adapt as companies
i've been grinding so hard for the last
three four five years and i know you
have too you've been going hard man
you'd be going 20 times harder than
anyone i know
oh you go you do too and and that's why
you know your businesses have flourished
school of greatness is blown up all the
books you've sold i mean let's be real
brother you do too
and for me i've been one of the great
blessings of this has been
you know i've been putting things out
all the time and maybe some of you feel
that way at your work
i've really taken a chance like you're
one of my best friends
i listened to your show when i could
before you listened to mine when you
could
i've consumed probably 30 of your
podcasts in the last four weeks
andy furcella who's my partner in the
rta syndicates like
for the first time in many months i'm
like wow this show's amazing tom village
is amazing you know like
i'm letting myself i'm using this as a
chance in between
working i got to be honest with
everybody i have these couple homes you
see me and this is my wine room while
there's an
echo and i do it because i'm hiding from
family but
i basically i basically live in the sea
18 hours a day
and in my other home i live in my home
office so i haven't moved much but i am
taking it as an opportunity to grow as
my point i'm really
when this is done and they relaunch us
out into the world
that same version of you ain't gonna get
it done
because it's gonna be a little bit more
difficult you're gonna need momentum one
thing i keep telling everybody is
i'm booking my calendar for meetings in
may
and if i i don't want them to go okay
you can come back and i go
well monday's open wednesday's open
friday's open those either
you know have hair salons or businesses
where you meet with people
assuming you can schedule the meetings
now if you're wrong
you can reschedule them may 5th may 10th
may 15th
you don't want to get caught not ready
by nature i would say
that people are motivated by one of two
things either they're moving towards a
goal or they're moving away from a
problem i don't want to be broke i don't
want to be homeless i um
and then there's other people that are
like i want to achieve this goal i want
to win this i want to be the best
and knowing where you come from will
help you
navigate the world in a much more um
sane inducing way because if you're
being sort of true to what aligns with
you like for me
moving away from something is never very
interesting it takes me
into like a very uncertain a very uneasy
place whereas
even if i'm in the middle of massive
uncertainty and i have fears
for me to shift my energy i need to pick
a goal something that i'm excited about
so that when i'm pursuing it even though
the outcome is going to be that i outrun
this thing right
i've been broke i've had crazy debt i've
been in a place emotionally where i'm
laying on my carpet and i just
i don't have any idea how i'm going to
create momentum in my life so i know
what that's like
but the things that got me up and moving
were to believe that i could change to
believe that i could grow to set a goal
to to set a goal that i was excited
about
and then wake up every day and pursue
that and that was the thing that
it i think a big thing people have to do
is like
what where are you at as a baseline
reference point if you're in
looking at seeing all the problems and
all the things that are wrong
you're not in problem solving mode if
you can shift over into problem solving
mode so i've heard you talk about that
waffle
restaurant before and you gave the guys
some brilliant ideas about what to do
like
hey are you sending people text messages
and it's like yeah to be top of mind to
remind people
um you know to incept them but you have
to be in that problem-solving mode
yeah is that something that you
think about intentionally is that
something you try to train your team to
do
is that that to me seems like going back
to what you were saying at the very
beginning with your dad of like all
right you can look at you at the fact
that you lost or you can solve this
problem
yeah i think it's interesting too
because i look at most business owners
and like
i and i know for me i did i did it
backwards the first way like a lot of
times
we come up with our products or our
services like we have an idea like oh i
want to create this thing we create it
and then after it's done like now we've
got to figure out how to sell it and you
figure out like a cell's message and
create that and then it's like
now i gotta go find people to sell to
and then we're trying to find people and
it's like
it's like backwards like if you look at
the way that the most successful
businesses grow
i look at the way that we grew click
funnels was when i had this realization
of like
i don't want to go and like create
something and find somebody to sell to i
want to go find the people that
that that i'm passionate about serving
and then just listen really really
carefully right
and i always tell people like the the um
the more money you make is
uh will be like the money make will be
in direct relation to how simple you
make
uh somebody else's process right so for
me it's like i hope people build
funnels to sell their products and
services and so you know when i when i
taught people the strategies here here's
how you do it i made good money we made
software that made it simpler
i made more money we had like done for
you things making simpler and make more
money and it's always like
how do i simplify this process for
whoever the customers how do i make it
easier and and so like the mindset that
we're always having in our here at
clickfunnels and me and my team is like
we're sitting there and
listening to our audience like what is
it they're looking for what do they want
what are they struggling
and it's like okay how do we make this
process simpler and every good product
every good idea everything that's
that's been a winner came from that like
listening and then like figuring out how
to solve the problem
all the ones where it was like russell
has this great idea two in the morning
let me go let's go create it my whole
team gets together then we like try to
give it to people
those those are the ones that don't
typically do very well um
no matter how much like you know how
much push
force and money we put into it to try to
get adoption it's always harder than
the opposite way we're just listening to
what people want and figure out how is
the best way to solve that for them
and um anyway that's like the the
simplest thing is just listening and how
do we simplify this form how to simplify
and you'll get paid more the better you
become
simplifying processes and and things for
people
if you want more advice wisdom guidance
from other successful entrepreneurs on
how you can navigate the chronovirus
situation
check out the video right there next to
me i hope you find it valuable
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you will kick yourself in the ass
they're not taking advantage